Donald Trump has unfortunately for
Americans
once again completely embarrassed
himself and by extension embarrassed the
United States on the world stage at
yesterday's speech that he gave in front
of the United Nations General Assembly
now as a speech it was horrendous
extremely low energy it was that
mumbling stumbling Trump that often
appears to be coming down from uppers as
I've mentioned before that showed up to
yesterday's speech now hilariously there
were actually some journalistic
descriptions of the speech that called
it sober and respectful which are the
most polite possible words that you can
assign to downer Trump the version of
Trump that shows up when he is in that
coming down from uppers sort of mode
that we've identified before
now of course Donald Trump used a
teleprompter which also helps to keep
Trump in that low-energy mode something
remember he made fun of barack obama for
using when Barack Obama was president it
turns out I guess
that using a teleprompter and being able
to read leads to far better speeches
than using a teleprompter and struggling
to read which is what Donald Trump does
every single time he uses that prompter
but it wasn't just the style of Trump
speech that was atrocious the content of
the speech was disgusting as well this
was one of the most nationalist speeches
that Donald Trump has given criticizing
countries that in his view treat the
u.s. unfairly talking about being
against globalism and for patriotism
which is once again this tired
anti-semitic trope throwing in some
awkwardly worded deference to things
like treating people well and valuing
differences which we have no evidence
that actually suggests Trump believes or
even thinks is important and once again
Downard Trump is the guy that showed up
this is the one that appears to be
coming down from uppers slurring doing
the thing when s's exist in words
appearing to chew on his own teeth
stopping looking confused at the words
on the teleprompter take a look the
world fully expects that the Chinese
government will honor its binding treaty
it is time for Iran's leaders to step
forward America is ready to embrace
friendship with all who genuinely seek
peace the receiving countries are
overburdened with more migrants and they
can responsibly accept nations that
empower women are much wealthier safer
and much more relatively stable
Americans will never fire or tire in our
effort to defend and promote freedom
Liberty is only preserved sovereignty is
only secured yesterday I was also
pleased to host leaders for a discussion
about an iron Clair American commitment
extraordinarily strange behavior I mean
just again genuinely strange behavior
that I've heard no reasonable
explanation for so far let's look at
another moment from the speech here
where Donald Trump does his globalism
bad patriotism good thing a free world
must embrace its national foundations it
must not attempt to erase them or
replace them looking around and all over
this large magnificent planet the truth
is plain to see if you want freedom take
pride in your country if you want
democracy hold on to your sovereignty
and if you want peace love your nation
wise leaders always put the good of
their own people and their own country
first the future does not belong to
globalists the future belongs to
Patriots the future belongs to sovereign
and independent nation
who protect their citizens respect their
neighbors and honor the differences that
make each country special and unique it
is why we in the United States have
embarked on an exciting program of
national we know we're not globalists
but we are patriots now as I mentioned
already extremely low energy so energy a
so low energy in fact that one of Donald
Trump's cabinet secretaries slept
through the speech we'll talk about that
a little bit later but more importantly
looking awful sounding awful and the
content being ridiculous
the entire criticizing globalists thing
has an ugly anti-semitic past whether or
not Donald Trump knows that whether or
not Donald Trump is deliberately
referencing it for that reason but it's
a dog whistle for Jews that has been
around for a very very long time but
it's important not to miss the bigger
picture here which is that the United
States is increasingly not part of the
serious and important conversations that
world leaders around the world are
having trying to solve some of the big
problems of our time the big picture is
that Donald Trump's reference to an
anti-semitic trope shouldn't be allowed
to distract us from an increasingly
cornered and backpedaling Donald Trump
on his excuses for why he would withhold
the hundreds of million dollars in aid
from Ukraine because he wanted them to
smear Joe Biden while suppressing a
whistleblower and in the end it becomes
difficult to even figure out which
ridiculous public embarrassment or
crisis is meant to be a distraction from
some other sometimes even worse
ridiculous public embarrassment but
embarrassing himself on the world stage
is something that has become
unfortunately all too common under this
presidency I know that the trumpets
don't agree with me and I know that they
also don't care what other countries
think about Trump and in fact they
become emboldened when they hear that
other countries are not even including
Trump in conversations about climate
change for example
countries are not even including Trump
in conversations about how can we get
Iran back into compliance with the Iran
nuclear deal particularly given that
Trump bailed on the deal without Iran
having actually broken any of the
conditions of that deal and when we look
at the coverage of something like the UN
General Assembly here in the United
States we understandably have a very
Trump centric view either people who
love what Trump did or anybody who has a
good head on their shoulders and
realizes the embarrassing nature of what
Trump did in other countries it's not
just that they are much more unanimous
in their understanding that what Trump
said is ridiculous
it arguably even worse where it doesn't
even really matter what Donald Trump is
doing and saying because other countries
are increasingly not even including the
United States in important conversations
about so many of the issues that are
facing humanity right now and that's the
real tragedy that it will take a long
time to undo once Donald Trump is no
longer president